hey everyone my name is Saul I work at
Quon site and today I'll be talking
about a project I've been working on for
the past year or so it's pretty
experimental and more of a idea at this
point than something you can go download
and make your life better so if if
that's what you're looking for I won't
be offended if you leave halfway through
the presentation or right now but I
wanted to present it here be oh yeah
sure but I wanted to present it here
just to get some feedback from other
people and also because this is a
library marketed towards other people
making libraries in Python so this is
not something necessarily an end user
would be it would be useful to them but
it's more for you know other people
making libraries like pandas or Ibis to
you know help those kind of libraries
work together so before that I'm gonna
start with a little narrative and so it
starts with how do we make our code
faster so can everyone see this so the
other thing is that we have a pretty
small group here so if there are
questions or comments
half way through feel free to just raise
your hand and we can get to them as I'm
presenting so we have this code in
Python it's iterating through a loop
it's doubling every item in that loop
and then it's indexing and it takes some
amount of time and we might want that to
go faster for our application so what
are some ways that you could speed up
this code any ideas
generators okay so changing the code so
that it goes goes quicker
I okay so maybe less operations that are
happening in the end-use number right so
we look at the whole program as one and
then we kind of compile it so overall
there's like pretty much there's kind of
two strategies here one is we could make
the code faster through some
optimizations or we could just get
better hardware right we could get a
faster CPU so first let's look at how we
make the code faster so that the classic
way not using numba or anything fancy
would just be to switch to numpy right
and so we have some pretty similar code
but it runs a lot quicker and it runs
quicker because each part each
instruction basically is running less
instructions on the CPU right and maybe
it's allocating less memory so this is
like besides make tools like numba this
is sort of classically how we'd get
better performance in Python is writing
tools like numpy and scifi and pandas
and they call out to write C libraries
instead of doing everything in the
Python interpreter so this kind of
mental model of how to speed up Python
is built around the von Neumann
architecture so this is the architecture
of your CPU but it's also the
architecture of Python itself right as a
model so for this code to run if we look
back at this code what it's doing is
it's fetching you know it's touching
something from memory it's executing
some instruction on it then it's saving
that back in memory so if if we look at
our CPU as you know a little unit that's
doing this we can look at Python as like
a isomorphism of that CPU but at a
higher level right so maybe we're not
dealing with you know you know bits
anymore but we're dealing with you know
larger blocks of memory and it's still a
very much sequential process then when
we switch to something like number like
you mentioned that's kind of inverting
this right we're not speeding it up by
making this particular line faster we're
speeding up by looking at the whole
program as a unit and optimizing it so
that's some of the difference I'm going
talking about today but if we look so
many of our languages today are von
Neumann based right like java javascript
mainly the only time we so some that
aren't are like sequel right or if we
use more functional kind of programming
techniques or instead of you know
keeping everything as a sequential list
we're looking at optimizing the program
as a whole and so how does this relate
to where we are in Python it it relates
because there's been a change in how
hardware has been improving so if you
see here this is the transistors are
still going up exponentially right so
this is Moore's law saying that we'll
have exponential growth in the
transistors but the frequency here has
kind of plateaued in the past I don't
know 10 15 years so what this means is
that if we use our von Neumann kind of
architecture of Python which is like
make all the ins you know use less
instructions if you can by using like
numpy and get faster CPUs every year and
things will just get better right this
is kind of the world we've been in this
is ending or it has ended so we can no
longer depend on running through this
sequential model to make our programs
faster instead what we see here is we're
seeing an increase in number of cores so
we're moving from a model that is just
one CPU to possibly many CPUs and and
even more than that so I have some
physics here but I don't really
understand the physics so I'm not gonna
explain it but there's some you know
laws about computing scaling and blah
blah blah thermodynamics I don't know
things get too small and then you can't
make them faster or something like that
but the end result is is the plot
basically right the CPU frequencies
aren't going up but so we don't just see
like that we're getting multiple CPUs we
see other kinds of optimizations right
like pipelining and your CPUs so instead
of being the sequential process really
it's a parallel process now it's just
hidden from you as the user right or
caching at the memory level right or
things like GPUs or Asics or FPGA
or other custom ships the reason why
we're having to move to those now is
because we're we can't get the same
performance on the CPU which had this
simple mental model relatively simple
mental model compared to these custom
chips so what this is leading to is that
we have here like really an intellectual
bottleneck about that we're thinking
about our programs as you know hey I
have some memory and I have some
processor right and I want to I need to
be shoveling more bits back and back
back and forth to make it faster and the
issue with just thinking about how do we
decrease maybe that one instruction to
be you know that yet that you know a
range to be an umpire a range is that
we're not really thinking about the
whole process we're just thinking about
this one instruction how do we make it
quicker so we what we want to be
thinking is like you know things like
numba these larger conceptual units
right so this was back in 1990 1977 this
quote about the von Neumann architecture
versus you know freeing us basically
from lock locking ourselves in as
programmers to tying ourselves to this
kind of mental model right so if we can
if we can have programming abstractions
that aren't built around there then we
can target other types of hardware as
well right so it frees us from sticking
to this kind of sequential computation
and so this today I mean we see this in
the field with things like numba with
things like tensorflow right so there's
no longer this is a tensor for some sort
of visualization of a tensor flow graph
and and it's non sequential if there's
things happening in parallel and the
other part of it is that it's not tied
to some specific hardware architecture
right it's expressing the domain that
you want and then we're then taking that
tensor flow graph and compiling it to
different hardware architectures so it's
trying to take our programming model and
bringing it sort of like slightly up a
level so we're talking about our domain
instead of talking about how we're
actually executed or instruct
and this is this is complicated so it's
the reason why I think numpy and sci-fi
and these things were built as they are
is because it's it's simpler
conceptually to just think about hey
like I have some memory and you know I
want to execute on it quick more quickly
so I write it in C instead of writing in
a Python right you get a speed-up
they're fine but if you if you then
start thinking about hey I have this
whole program of all these mathematical
operations and not only do I want it to
run on my one CPU but I want it to run
on a GPU or an FPGA or some other you
know hardware that's gonna come out next
year that I don't even know what the
instruction set is gonna be like or
furthermore it's not going to be a
sequential kind of instruction set how
do i how do we build our software around
those kinds of optimizations so why
because it's harder I think we're seeing
some innovation in vertically integrated
stacks right like so if you say let me
stick to the Google stack let me use
chaos let me use tensor flow let me use
jacks instead of number then you kind of
get this nice world in a way where you
can say hey you know I'm just building
my tensor flow graph and I'll let other
people take care of where it's gonna run
right and and so it gives users this
nice abstraction and the the point here
is that these other hardware vendors
like Intel AMD Nvidia these all these
little blocks are their own languages
basically our hardware so things like n
graph or open V know are in themselves
their own you know set of instructions
and languages that these hardware
vendors have described so that you can
run efficiently on they're growing you
know diversity of chips so as a Python
user right I want to just write my code
and have it run on all of these options
and more in the future right and I as an
ecosystem we need to be able to support
having libraries that can run on you
know so that you have your front-end API
that users target but then that is
modular enough to you know move
to new platforms as they become
available because users don't they don't
care about this they care about hey I
bought some new GPU maybe and I want it
to run faster or I want to throw some
money at this and paralyzed in the cloud
like they don't want to care about what
I are using in the middle to go from my
pandas to you know my output but as I as
a community right now we they kind of
have to care right they have to pick do
I import Cu DF or do I import pandas go
import desc
like so this is just growing as a
community sort of the users are now
forced to you know choose a library
right and this is even more so the case
with the deep learning libraries like
tensorflow and pi torch where the api's
are incompatible so you write your whole
stack on top of one of these and then
you're now stuck with it so we have this
kind of buy-in problem so let's take a
step back and let's look at some
examples well at first we want to say
yes so there's all these great things in
Python that we love and basically what
this talk is about is situating this
problem that we want to lease things to
work but we want them to work in the
future and for the future of hardware
and performance optimizations in Python
and then I'm going to look through some
specific ways we might be able to think
about that yeah and I was just in Peter
Wang's talk which was about sort of the
the the having a instead of having goals
based approach having like a values
based kind of approach and open source
and so it helped frame this talk a bit
because it's less about like you know
specifically o running these things
quicker but it's more about what are the
values as an ecosystem that we want to
put forward as we make this you know
support for these new hardware and new
software right so we want things like we
want it to be decentralized right we
want to be it'll cooperate we don't want
you don't want to have to work at one
company to be able to you know play in
this ecosystem right we want to
encourage innovation so if you have some
new way of optimizing you should be able
to plug in plug in without you know
causing a lot of pain to users so it's
more so about like what is what is the
ethos we want to bring to this ecosystem
moving for
and then how can the technology it
should be supporting us get getting
there right so first I just let's just
start with the simplest way that we
might think about this in Python and
then we can kind of show how that's not
not enough at the moment so who here is
familiar with my PI and typing does
anyone in ported these modules to okay
so my PI is a static type checker for
Python and Python now provides typing
module and typing extensions module so
that you can say this is sort of like an
interface right and you can say that you
know my code corresponds to interface so
this is it's a it's a concept that's
very natural in Python but this is just
a way to be concrete about it so this is
called protocol so the idea here is we
have some object which supports indexing
and it supports adding and it's worth
indexing by integers and it supports
adding with itself to you know give a
new array so we might say okay let's
standardize right like why don't we all
standardize and let's come up with some
great protocol here for arrays or for
data frames and then we can all
cooperate right like that sounds good so
let's see how we maybe use this right so
then we'd have some function that would
say oh I can take this kind of array and
I can do some kind of fancy operation
with it
and then we might want to say okay so
now let's create an implementation of it
it's create an implementation that uses
numpy arrays under the hood so this is
it
it just forwards the so we you know you
pass in an umpire a and it forwards the
indexing to the numpy array and the
adding to the numpy array and so then we
could create an umpire array with a
range so let's maybe we should run this
code how about since we're in a notebook
you create some numpy array and now
we're you know this we can you know call
these functions on it like get item and
adding and right it works fine so now
let's say let's do this with torch right
so this is you know not that exciting
but we do the same thing with the torch
array
and then we can call the torch a range
okay this is all fine and good but there
are some issues here first you noticed I
had to change the a range function from
numpy to torch right so as I as a user
you still have to know kind of like what
paradigm you're picking right and so
imagine this a range was inside of this
function somewhere far away then how do
you as a user you come to this and said
well now I want to run it on torch so
you have to go rewrite your code and
rewrite your imports to now use PI torch
instead of numpy right so that means
that there's a pretty big barrier to
entry for people switching from numb PI
to PI tortured PI torch to numpy which
means it's less likely that we can
innovate as an ecosystem if people have
to go and rewrite all their imports if
they want to try out a new library
Travis gave a talk yesterday on ura
which is another approach here which
does let you have a global sort of
override where you can say use this
context like use the PI torch context
and then when I call you or a dot a
range it'll use the PI torch function so
that in turn gets us part of the way
there right gets us closer because now
we can have a global context and you can
write your libraries that are just
dependent on you know the interface that
we provide this one and they shouldn't
depend on the particular implementation
but let's see if we can make that a
little bit more concrete so this is a
similar interface but there's no actual
definition here what's it's like it
looks like the protocol right it looks
like a typing description of what you
want but what we can actually do we so
we can write our same function so we can
actually call this on a range and we get
a result well what's our result well
it's just it's just the function that we
want to execute right so it's just a way
of saying hey before we actually execute
anything let's let's take a step back
let's build up everything that we want
to do and then we can decide how we want
to do it right and so this the point of
this is that it it it has a very clean
barrier between
people who are consuming an API and
people who are providing the API if
you're consuming the API like this
function there's no way you're gonna
know what's inside of those arrays you
can't like so the problem we have with
numpy today is that some people
consuming numpy look inside the numpy
array and say hey this is a pointer to
you know a bunch of memory and C and I'm
gonna do some fancy stuff on it because
it's faster which is cool right that's
great but then it means you can't use
that library with another numpy array
without hitting an issue and there's no
way to right now those things are tied
together right so we don't know who's
depending on the numpad PII versus the
numpy implementation and so with with
this approach it forces those things to
be divorced or you if you depend on the
implementation that's all you get I
really sorry the API that's all you get
so then you might ask okay so what do we
do with this right how do we actually
evaluate it before I get there I just
want to show you sort of like how this
works internally because it's it's
pretty simple even though we get this
kind of fancy graph so I also work on
Jupiter laughs so I made a Jupiter lab
extension to show this graph here so but
I want to show you how how this is
actually implemented so I have this I
have this expression here
and I can see what function did I call
to get it so I called getitem right this
was the last function that I called to
get this expression and I can also look
at its args it said the two args are the
sorry the adding and then the five so
the the the implementation of this is
pretty simple it's just this expression
object is that class that holds three
things the function the args and the
kwargs so it basically just records
right what you've done so instead of
it's it's like if people are familiar
with match PI or other expression
systems it's just like those but instead
of having to write hey this is an
operator which takes three arguments and
the first one needs to be the second one
needs to be this you just write a Python
function right and so then you decorate
it with this and then we call the
function it builds up the expression so
the other way I could have done this is
something like this I just say hey I'm
making an array the function is a range
the args are you know ten and their note
kwargs alright so this this here is the
same as doing this alright so this is
this decorator this met a DSL expression
decorator all it does is it takes this
call here and it creates an array object
out of it all right so the magic here is
is is really not much it and it's all
relying on the typing annotations which
are compatible with my PI so you just
write the typing annotations and then it
figures out hey I'm calling a range I
need to get an int and the object that
it returns should be an array so you get
an array out so that's all like fine for
how to make something but then what do
you actually do with it right how do you
evaluate it so it in some ways meta DSL
is two parts it's this first part hey I
want to make some expressions that are
typed in Python using classes and
functions you know that's a good base
for an expression
that feels pretty natural to use the
other part is a pattern matching system
so that you can say hey I have this
graph of expressions now let me replace
it to evaluate it in some way so let's
show an example let's say we want to
just think similar as we did before
where we have an UMP I array
implementing this interface so we make a
function that takes some numpy array and
creates one of our array classes and so
now we can I mean we can call this if we
want wait we can say
all right so we can call this and we
could say at it right because this is
what we defined but we still haven't
defined how addition works right so we
see we have an ADD call on to numpy
raise so now what we should do is you
should read a rule that says hey if I'm
trying to add two numpy arrays let me
add the arrays themselves right so
that's what we do here we say let's
create a number of rules that will
execute repeatedly until no more are
done and they'll execute recursively
across the expression and if we set it
to the default then it'll show up as the
wrapper in my notebook so this is one
for a range so now we made a rule here
so we can say hey if I say a range 10
right it starts out as this this a range
call of 10 and then this rule executes
and it calls numpy a range and it wraps
that an array from numpy so the point
here is that as you're executing the
rules the types never change
so it still all should type check right
you still even though this is an array
this is an array right but the
Constructors may be change right so this
is how you would write the execution
then we can add the other rules for
adding and get item and then we can take
our original expression that we had
before right and we can see how it
evaluates to the result
okay that's all fine but we could do
that before right like there's nothing
really fancy there so now what we're
gonna show is okay great
we have this expression system now what
we want to do is like what I was talking
about before looking at the larger
conceptual units this is what it lets us
do we can build up you know say a string
that represents our expression that we
want to execute so here instead of
taking an umpire a and making it an
array we're taking a string and so we
see that like for example to add strings
we're just doing string concatenation
and then index we're doing string
indexing so then you know you start with
something like this and you end up with
just a string right and then you could
see you could feed this through numb
expert or numba or something like that
to actually get you know an optimized
result or compile it to some other
back-end still this is all stuff we
could have done just with our
dispatching kind of approach so the
advantage we get here is that we can do
higher level optimizations that require
building up multiple forms before
executing them so here we have an
optimization that says when I'm adding
two arrays and then indexing index first
right so this should do less work maybe
because we're not having to add the
whole arrays we can just add the one
element we've indexed out and this sort
of thing isn't like it's impossible to
write right now with numpy right there's
no way to put this in the numpy code
base because it doesn't build it build
up an expression at the moment and so
the so the other thing in here is we can
look at kind of how this syntax works so
we write our replacement rule this is
the left hand side this is the right
hand side it says this is what we want
to match against and this is what we
want to replace it with and and the
point of meta DSL it doesn't do anything
that fancy it just integrates well with
Python so we have Python types here that
it matches against and this all type
checks as well so you can run my PI over
these rules and it will tell you at
compile time like is what you're doing
sensible right are the right types being
passed in everywhere
so it gives us a nice fluent interface
to write these kind of optimization
rules so we can add this rule and we can
say hey now instead of just doing our
symbolic rules let's first do any
optimizations we have and then do our
symbolic rules so we see we can start to
build rules into groups and then decide
how those groups execute either
repeatedly or in order so we can see
here we have our initial array and then
our optimization runs and now we're
adding at you know the indexed items
instead of indexing the added items and
the beauty here is then we can keep our
existing rules so this would work either
with the symbolic arrays or the numpy
rays and we can get our result so the
point here is really social right the
point is that one organization or group
can write the array interface another
organization or group can write a
certain back-end for it and then a third
can write optimizations and this is a
very simple example here but the the
concept is that you don't just have the
numpy array API you might have a smaller
array API that's you know a lot of the
numpy like array api's are very similar
right like things like zeros or ones you
could say reducing this down to a like a
smaller subset right like that might
make sense so then people are writing
backends don't have to support the whole
API they can just support a smaller
subset so but users can still use the
whole API because why you know make
their lives harder why change what they
know so so the idea there is that users
write for the large API we write you
know replacement rules that goes to a
smaller API and then that smaller API is
what people can target and so this is a
system that you could use to do
something like that right so it gives us
the space as a community to say hey we
have the numpy API it's great oh cool I
have my smaller API that the nut PI API
can compile into and then I can go from
that smaller API to other backends and
it lets us as a community each you know
take on those different projects and
cooperate without forcing us to all
being you know one organization or one
codebase
so just to show another you know example
here we can say hey you know the repeat
operator from numpy let's say if I'm
adding you know a bunch of zeros I can
just remove that so just kind of wanted
to show that we can match against
specific values so I can say hey if I'm
adding against you know a repeating zero
of any length you know return that just
to be that original array
right so then we can well hopefully
remove out that repeat there and so yeah
so that's that's sort of the concept and
then I want it to tie it to a few other
sort of terminologies or ways of
thinking about this just may be as
helpful in if you're talking to others
so the the one way to think about these
things as domain-specific languages so
one way to write domain-specific
languages is to write your own
interpreter right like this is maybe
like sequel or you know if you said I'm
gonna go off and write my own syntax and
parse it myself so those are standalone
and you can do those but they require a
lot more work right and so this is why
we see people like you know tensorflow
they don't they're not writing their own
language they're embedding it in Python
right so we can use all the existing
facilities like printing etc in Python
to write our domain-specific languages
and then the difference here between
like say numpy today and this approach
is the difference between deep and
shallow embedding so so with the with
the deep embedding like so here it says
deep embedding you construct an AST and
the shallow embedding you evaluate the
terms as they you know as they execute
right so that's what we saw in our first
example right we just had our API it's
still a domain-specific language we're
defining our API but it's shallowly
evaluated it's evaluated directly as we
create the terms they're all evaluated
and the advantage of the you know the
deep embedding is that it gives us more
room to play with it right it gives us a
kind of breathing room to say hey before
we go and execute all this stuff let's
just take a second to think about what
we want to do and make some choices
there looking at the whole program the
other the other way I've been looking at
this recently is about code data versus
data
so I guess code data is a term from
logic but the idea is that so
here data is concerned about how values
are constructed and code data is
concerned about how they are used
so codata
is about how they are used right so if
we have some boolean operator and python
how does it how to use a boolean in the
end it all comes down to one statement
the if statement right you can construct
and anything else out of the if
statement so if we talk about the codata
of bool it's this if statement right so
in the code data of our array was the
indexing and the get item but the data
of the boolean is may be like the Python
bool right or in the array case a numpy
array or you know a tensorflow array so
by meta dsl lets us separate these two
concepts so that we can talk very
concretely about code data without
mixing it up with all the data and so we
so this is an example here we can say
hey we can say you know if I have a true
bool then it should evaluate to its left
side if I have a false pool at your
value to its right side all right so
then we can start building up these
kinds of concepts and executing them and
that the point is that code data lets us
talk about interfaces that is in a
language agnostic way so you're not
talking anymore about
hey what's in memory like what's my int
type what's my you know float type
you're talking about the API in a way
that's abstracted away from your
particular language implementation so
yeah as usual there was no way to open
up a higher-order function one example
of a co datatype and expect inspect the
way it was implemented so the problem
with numpy is that people can open it up
I mean the problem the advantage right
it's fine it works but that's the issues
that people can open up an umpire brecht
and try to look at what it is and so
that it then it makes scikit-learn not
you know work on say something that
looks like numpy but really isn't so as
a community this is like sort of an idea
of can we be more explicit about our
code data and about defining these
interfaces so that when you depend on
something you know what you're getting
is just the interface you're not getting
the execution just another kind of
example of this is here is how we define
a Fibonacci
so we can see it looks like you know it
feels pretty much like Python besides
that can the control flow so this is one
issue with this framework at the moment
and Python at the moment is that you
can't override control flow and this is
the same issue that tensorflow is having
that PI torch is having and they're
having to write either tracers where you
decorate your function or like number
right number has to inspect the IR and
analyze the whole IR so so this is sort
of a language level issue that I think
we could be solved or hopefully we will
solve at the language level like a form
of quoting or some sort some form of
being able to say hey I have some
control flow but I don't want it to
execute how Python executes my control
flow right I want to build up some kind
of expression and this also kind of
shows the difference between this
approach and Python like this builds up
a graph which is you know strictly
functional and Python is very imperative
right so you do have these where those
things meet you have some friction right
so we need and this is you know comment
in the compiler community you might have
one abstraction that's just you know
control flow heavy and then one that's
about data flow and it's you know
they're both useful for different things
it's not like one you know is the
end-all be-all but in in this kind of
API conversation the functional form is
much more useful because then we don't
have to worry as much about mutating
state right so if we can go more easily
from Python this imperative kind of
control flow to this functional control
flow then this will help us build you
know fluent API is for users but that
compile down to different backends so
this you know this works but it's a
little ugly right you have to kind of do
this functional if sort of thing yeah so
I wanted to end on a nice picture of
Guido and a quote from him from 1999 for
his computing for everybody grant where
he said we're looking forward to a
future where every computer user will be
able to open the hood of their computer
and make improvements the application
inside and so if we think about that
chart earlier with Google and the
different hardware vendors
I think what you know I'm hoping is that
we can look for a future in Python where
people feel empowered to to open up any
level of that stack and make
improvements or innovations or Forks
right and they're supported to do that
by the kind of tooling that we have so
thank you that was my talk happy to take
any questions
when behind the scenes
so the yeah so I think maybe two parts
just let's see let's go back to this
image so one thing is yet we're we're
compiling to these so we're not handling
the runtime in any way right we're not
saying we're gonna have a better runtime
we're just gonna say we can get to your
runtime that you want right and so there
is some cost in terms of like
optimization right doing all this work
is not free but I think what we can do
is we can make those trade-offs in a
more in like controlled manner so
hypothetically you have this you have an
abstract way of you know compiling you
could then compile äôt to something like
numpy right so you if you look at number
right it has some äôt capabilities so
it's like if you take that sort of idea
of something like number but then we say
hey can we build our whole stack like
this and just the compiled library is
just an artifact of our more general
library so then for people who want
either AXA queue ssin they just want to
execute in CPU fine same cost right I
think the cost is an abstraction cost
like this is way more complicated than
writing Python code and part of that is
also the language isn't support like
it's not built for this it's not how
people thought about writing Python code
so I've talked to there's a few other
folks working on similar thing so one of
the things is debugging is really a pain
for this kind of thing like you need to
be able to match trace backs if you want
this to be useful so that when the user
gets some error they know oh it is
generating LVM but really it came from
this file over here so that's an
unsolved sort of problem or I mean
they're in Python at least right so it
does introduce a lot more complexity
it's not simple
I don't know that answers yeah
well the äôt is what has to separate the
end-user so there's at least three
different camps right there's the people
who are writing the interface there may
be a distributor like anaconda or
somebody like that who can pilot to a
particular target thing yeah there's the
user yep
yeah
well what was one
your new array is really fast and it's
way less complex and so it doesn't
handle any of the lazy part it's so it's
a go back going back to the DSL
definition yeah so it's shallowly
embedded this is deeply embedded so you
can't do you can't build up big forms
and then do optimizations on them with
you array I mean so what we've
experimented with with you are a is fine
use your a you can use your right to
build up this graph I mean that's one
possible way to use them together if
they were say both used yeah so this
also fits with I don't know how many
people are following the numpy like
extension story that's going on right
now but there's currently ways to sort
of say hey I have a custom numpy array
so that when it goes through the numpy
codebase it calls its methods instead of
the numpy methods and so this also it
doesn't replace that at all right it
would fit with it so you could say hey
if numpy supports that then you could
pass one of these objects through the
numpy code base and you get basically an
AST of what you want to compute at the
end so all of the extension stuff going
on in numpy it's not like this is a you
know it would rely on it basically if
users were to continue using numpy as is
the one thing that you can't do with the
numpy story is like override a range
right or there they're all they're doing
it based on type so it's all based on
type dispatching so it'd be like the
type of the int you pass into a range
has to be a torched int for it to call
the tort PI torch a range so you can't
do this kind of like divorce there but
yeah anyway
I guess I wanted to ask with your
optimization how much are you going to
be able to capture optimizers like LLVM
or number or all these all this existing
knowledge yeah that's a great question
and I think that's the kind of
conversation we should be having right
and we should be having it through
building these different you know IRS
sub languages and seeing how to
translate from one to the other because
that's when really the collaboration
gets unlocked right when you can say hey
I have this intermediate representation
for a raise that does a bunch of
optimizations and we can share it now
across backends and this is what Google
is doing with ml ir I don't know if
anyone's familiar with that but it's a
meta IR that they're using for LLVM and
tensorflow and it's a similar sort of
idea as this but it's in C++ so I think
if we can move to answering that
question then we'll be in a great state
cool thank you
[Applause]